general manager of the New York Jets
Mike mechag ninh here on the Rich Eisen
show how are you Mike Goodrich how you
doing I'm do give me your favorite
charlie casually story just to start
this thing off oh no you put me on the
spot all come on oh it's all good let's
see a kid Lord I don't I don't know if I
know a good one off the top of my head
there's like I said so much time with
them I think that the one thing I would
say with Charlie is having worked with
Charlie for so many years and when your
chance to get your good chance got to
see him on TV there's a little bit of
like you know there's a little like you
know there's a way that tardy has these
mannerisms that I'm just sort of
inflections in his voice but I'm so used
to hearing all the time yeah I was like
working with him and of course to see
him doing it like on TV it kind of
cracks me up a little bit makes me laugh
but I love Charlie he was a great guy to
work for and really from a mentorship
standpoint I mean he was always very
very matter almost like a being like a
teacher when I worked with him and try
to explain things and and really helped
me uh obvious prepare the job currently
and well it's interesting that the the
what just happened at the top of this
draft might be since the NFL network's
been covering at the very least the
biggest surprise since the top of this
year's draft was going from Mario
Williams instead of Reggie Bush and I'm
sure we're in for that whole discussion
yeah I remember that I remember that
whole thing very distinctly and the
other one too was Vince Young that year
because of course being in Houston that
was a bit of a hometown favorite you
know having been Vince was actually from
Houston so but no that was a big deal
that was there I remember that one in
fact now obviously a new kind of in
advance what we're gonna do but but you
know what really rich it's a different
NFL now because back then you had the
ability to actually you know enter
negotiations with the player and you
know before the draft start and I think
at that point I believe you know you had
the ability to kind of reach at this you
know agents and start talking about
being the first pick and of course that
obviously turns right around and leaked
out to the media so yeah nowadays it's a
little different like he and even this
year's draft it was kind of you know
kind of not knowing what was gonna
happen to one usually have a little bit
of a feel as you get closer to it it
kind of firms up but this year was
obviously the right to last minute I'd
yeah we weren't really sure what was
gonna happen in one and I would unfolded
you know not only have to surprise us
but it was a little it was interesting
it wasn't something we had kind of
thought of potentially happening they
a lot of research we did until literally
the day of the draft so you mike mechag
no jets general manager here on the Rich
Eisen show so what would you term
yourself as you're sitting there
watching the Commissioner name Baker
Mayfield if not surprised well I would
say you know it was interesting the you
know and the previous drafts I've been
in and you know obviously I've been that
I felt for many years but as a general
manager at least like when Leo when
Leonard Williams came out came out you
know we were at six maybe about four or
five days before the draft their
services some grumblings is like who was
gonna go you know and what spot and we
knew there's some good players and a
draft we knew there's a chance a good
player would fall to us but about four
or five days in advance we started
really gonna feel that here made a
viable scenario that Leonard would would
be there at six and we feel very good
about that and that opportunity last
year with Jamaal again maybe a few days
out to three days out we started we you
know so I get a feel for where how the
draft may fall out and we realized that
six we may have a chance to get Jamaal
this year you know and we did a lot of
work and we felt pretty well prepared
for this draft especially made the trade
up from six to three but this year you
know leading up to it there's a little
you know a number of different names are
kind of floating around and we always
kind of thought Sam was sort of a
consistent one and that spottily said so
a lot of the you know the impression we
had from a lot of information we were
gathering but really the day of the
draft that's when there was some
late-breaking an early information news
that it may be Baker Mayfield so that
was that was interesting and you know of
course as a draft unfolded you never
really know what's going to happen so
you're on the clock and you know we're
like everybody else sort of sitting
there watching and trying to get you
know figure out who's who was actually
getting the phone call and we saw Baker
take the call that we realize it was him
and you know not necessarily surprised
he's a good player his own right but but
again you know I think our impression
was you know all through the process
that Sam would have probably picked it
you know one and then there's always
just possible scenario two and then the
other scenario but maybe somebody
trading up the two to take him or maybe
the jobs would trade out of that pick or
you know we knew they liked the running
back quite a bit and say Kwan they got a
heck of a player in him but yeah I just
kind of unfolded it wasn't but I think
really do so much work in advance you
just you're very calm I'm very calm
during the draft and
kind of wait and see what falls to you
and of course when it presented itself
we felt you know very good that you know
they take Sam in the third spot there
were a lot of like I said but when we
made the trade up we felt very good
sitting at three so we felt over doing a
really good position there so so let me
ask you this question Mike the cognate
had Donald gone first
and you had a choice between Mayfield
and Rosen who would you have taken well
you know it's interesting my I remember
John Dorsey said his wife didn't even
know who their intake with a number one
pick that was a red flag Mike that was a
red flag that's not that's a red I know
I know but now I think differently
honest were very happy but were Sam you
know and obviously we made the decision
with him there and you know I don't
really get into hypotheticals and other
scenarios but there are some really good
players in this draft
you know Baker we thought very highly of
along with Josh so we felt it was a and
even you know Josh Allen and Josh Rose
and so you know we really felt we were
in a good position we made that trade up
so we're just happy we got Sam and we're
excited to see how he doesn't go on
forward what do you make of the news
that Baker Mayfield's agent says the
Patriots were interested into what you
think of that you think there's anything
there well you know I you know you never
really know I mean I think it's you know
we don't always know what other teams
are thinking or doing you know anything
I would simply say the Patriots have to
come from very far back that would that
would be very hard I would think to get
all the way up to two but you never know
but most that stuff like you know I
think when you actually go into the
draft and you do so much work in
preparation for it and then you make
your picks from a team standpoint you
know you really don't look at the
hypotheticals I mean the media I think
tends to kind of analyze all that stuff
and but of course I mean literally maybe
it's in the passing conversation but for
the most part we're more focused on like
getting back to work and trying to fair
ways to make this team better so that's
you know I don't give that too much
thought but I just to go all the way
from with a patriot or picking at thirty
one to two is just a long way to go you
know and of course what they would have
to give up to get there would be well I
really wouldn't know I would be
interesting few more minutes with Mike
McAra Jets general manager before I turn
the page about the future of the Jets I
do want to turn back to February and
March when you were making the decision
about what you were going to do in free
agency and the draft if there were all
these prospects like darn 'old
Rosen and Mayfield why make a play for
Kirk Cousins especially since it might
have given an indication to the person
with whom you're trading the idea that
you might not be getting Kirk Cousins if
you're knocking on his door to move up
in the draft Mike well I think rich so I
can kind of go back in time a little bit
so you know we do so much work and
prepare in preparation for the draft
we've done quite a bit of work on this
draft class and it felt really good not
and not just on the some of the higher
profile quarterbacks but other players
in the draft because really you have to
almost know that pools when trying to
make decisions about where to you know
you know again it's definitely make a
trade and where to position yourself but
if you go you know if we go back in time
a little bit I know myself and and you
know Brian heimerdinger my Mexican my
right hand you know we talked a lot
about that we talked about it with Todd
and ownership and about what you know
what her plan was because really what
you do is you sort of you map out Pro
free agency and then you map out and the
college draft to a certain degree you
don't really map out you really analyze
college draft you know try to make sure
you get your stack right but really you
put a lot in the pro free agency and of
course Pro free agency is a way you know
we feel least not like to add talent but
also to you know a certain degree build
and fill needs and build the roster so
when we went of the Pro free agency we
thought it was a unique scenario was
quite frankly Kirk Cousins being
available I think that was a that
doesn't happen very often in Pro free
agency I think everybody obviously has
talked about this where a quarterback
even though he was you know Lily 29 30
years old you know still going into the
prime of his career and we thought
played at a pretty high level so again
it's an opportunity in that market to
add a player so we felt hey you know
this is an income doesn't happen very
often we saw it was a bit of an amber
Asian just based on how the scenario
played itself out so we realized hey
this is a chance to go get a what we
felt was a very good quarterback now of
course as we're doing that and we
realized that hey it's Pro free agency
they can you know we can obviously you
know players can sign where they want to
sign and you obviously make your offers
competitive as you can make it and work
within your salary cap structure and
structure of how you save up your teams
but going into that you know as we're
kind of preparing ourselves and our free
agency plan to go try to land Kirk
Cousins
at the same time we're also claiming
ahead like okay what happens next and
that's where myself and Brian in
particular you know he you know he was
he was with me the whole the whole
process we figured out we decided that
okay if we don't get Kirk Cousins the
next thing to do is then to pivot in the
draft our pivot in preparation for the
draft try to do something that's a
little ahead of you know a little in
advance or a little preemptive and move
up in the draft to position ourselves to
you know take a very good player and of
course this was a draft with a lot of
good quarterbacks in it and we thought
you know as we sort of planned it we
position ourselves you know
realistically at three part of it was
for the compensation we did was ideally
hold on to our first-round draft pick
next year so we obviously paid a pretty
good price above market price for the
pick when you look at trade charts but
of course when you're dealing with
quarterbacks those trade turrets are
kind of skewed it can't go out the
window we also felt if we waited longer
and tried to make a trade closer to the
draft or if a player was sliding when
again there's more suitors in play you
know the idea would then you'd have to
pay more of a premium at that point in
time and by position ourselves with the
third pick with what we paid for it you
know we paid a little you know above
market value we thought it kind of made
the ability for somebody move ahead of
us even more difficult now whether or
not I have that played out that you know
to be determined but you know we felt
pretty good about that and and really if
you think back to pro free-agency when
we found out we were out of you know we
were the second team not the first team
for Kirk Cousins about the same time I
literally was on the road and Baker
Mayfield pro day at Josh Rosen's Protege
obviously done a lot of work on both
those guys am sand Arnold and Josh Allen
who had later pro days but we'd already
seen them at the combine we felt very
good about position ourselves in that
third spot especially when we were a
little facility to trade that allowed us
to keep our first and with having that
first going forward obviously took you
know in our minds are very good another
good piece to build with but if we opted
to hypothetically trade back in the
first round we have the ability to
regain or recoup our second-round draft
pick that we gave and move up in that
trade so that's really the you know the
thought process and the logic and then
of course when again when we missed out
on Kirk Cousins it was always you know
you penalties contingency plans in place
and we pretty much executed what our
plan was
and you know we kind of pivoted and went
out there reached out to Indy we kind of
tried to figure out what we could get in
terms of price and compensation and what
we'd have to give up and you know we
knew the Giants you know we knew our
impression from Cleveland was they were
going to stay at one and it would
definitely taken a king's ransom to try
to get that pick but they always seem to
be locked in at one and the Giants we
felt very strongly that they were going
to you know sit there at two in a very
in a very good position and to get a
very good player and you know whether it
was a quarterback they would take or
trade out or take one Barclays or
another player like we felt you know we
were gonna position ourselves well for
you know I mean the player we added I
will say this at the time we never you
know we went to all the scenarios of who
may be available in regards to Sam I
think we always sort of thought or
expected him to be um you know mother
first pick in the draft or possibly
second pick but when it played itself
out that it was available we felt very
good about it and you know and we're
very happy at that point time to make
that decision that but that being said
there's a lot of good players at three
we were very comfortably taken if it
wasn't him so then a couple quick
hitters for you Mike in the time in a
couple of minutes that we have left here
what is the plan force and Arnold what
to start this year yeah yeah I think I
think everybody you know Todd has said
this publicly talked about this
internally like you know how you know
what our plan is for Sam I think we're
going to you know as Todd said we're
gonna we're gonna you know basically
exposing everything we're gonna given
the opportunity to go out there earn
learn earn and earn the position but of
course we're you know our focus not
necessarily into the fire until he's
earned it and but we're very excited
about him and his upside in potential
and you know we have a lot of football
to people al spring and in training camp
and we'll see how it comes along he's
gonna have every opportunity to go out
there and hopefully fulfill all the
potential we see in them so he has the
opportunity to earn the job week one
basis we're sitting here right I would
say nothing's been predetermined one way
or the other and Todd's gonna make that
determines you know that decision after
we go through this offseason and yeah
that any chant I mean there's a chance
for anything in the table as essence has
been sort of set in stone in terms of
how we going to how we're going to do
this but you know in terms of a you know
a firm timeframe and but it's also gonna
be you know he's gonna have every
opportunity and we'll see how it
develops going forward and unless you
are gonna form two big three teams four
cubes big three league you're gonna have
to do something at the quarterback spot
in that room right Mike yeah yeah I
think you know we we
you know we have a decision to make here
and you know they'll work itself out
here and then you know kind of due
process due time
but again that's you know we have a
tough decision to make and you know
we're also feel very good about our you
know our team as a whole we're not where
we exactly want to be but we think we
have a very competitive room in that
quarterback room especially adding Todd
I'm sorry especially adding the Sam
Donald and we had Teddy Bridgewater and
Josh McCown the two young quarterbacks
Christian and Brice so we'll see how
this all plays out
all right lastly if you're in an airport
and a volleyball team of the school of a
top prospect that you're interested in
drafting is there and the coach says
talk to the girlfriend if you want to
know more about the prospect do you talk
to the girlfriend in the airport Mike
you know I think I think we're you know
we're like every other person out there
in terms of you always trying to gather
information um yeah you know it's funny
Alonzo is a good friend of mine and I
have the utmost respect for him but I
will say this I think we we do as a
league you know and what we do and I've
been I've been skating for a long time
you know it's a very subjective process
we gather lots of information on these
players not only how we evaluate a
muscle you know tape and live exposure
but I also gather a lot of information
because because in the end rich we're
trying to invest in a person so you know
you try to gather as much as you can and
go for it is that a no you don't know I
don't know if I've ever been in that in
that scenario before where I've been
around a volleyball team of a prospect
but I you know I would say simply you
know it's a little bit speculative I'm
not sure I think it's I'm not sure what
I would do quite frankly it might take
the fifth on that but like I said that
that was but a bit you probably
surprises how many people we actually
talk to you about doing our research on
these guys so Mike I've enjoyed our chat
let's not be strangers okay
surely at any time a man that's right
back at you that's Mike mechag NetJets
gentleman Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience